hey guys greg alba here so if you don't
have social media or friends who are
into movies or star wars or don't have
the internet you might not have heard
star wars episode 8 has an official
title the last Jedi and as you can guess
that I'm sure this has been leading to a
lot more speculation and theories as to
what episode 8 could actually be about
so i thought i'd chime in just a little
bit about what i think this could be
leading to and theorizing with this
title actually means based up a little
bit of information we already have about
the last Jedi with a report saying that
the film will take place immediately
after the events of the force awakens
and that there'll be Jedi training
sequences between Luke and Ray and
knowing from the events of the force
awakens that look at the last known Jedi
in the universe this title could simply
very well be referring to Luke Skywalker
even though it's not really in the force
awakens his existence was very much felt
and we barely saw him in the film so of
course we want to see a lot more of Luke
in the next Star Wars film so this title
could very well just be affirming that
we're going to see a lot more of Luke
Skywalker is called the last show I will
refer to loop but then diving a little
bit deeper into reports of like Mark
Hamill stating and I think it was an
interview with a Hollywood Reporter that
after episode age you'll be out of work
which made it sound like he's not signed
on for Episode nine so may me wonder is
it was so I'm going to be about Luke
training Ray Ray becomes an official
Jedi but then Luke Skywalker dies making
ray the last Jedi and was Adam driver
and john-boy I saying this film will be
darker it wouldn't surprise me if after
they kill off Han Solo and the force
awakens that they topped that gap with
killing off the one original cast member
that actually brings the galaxy some
real hope Luke Skywalker yeah as a
matter of fact even though I know all of
her scenes were shot I'll Harper it you
would it be if they killed off both Luke
and Leia in the same story honestly they
may be an interesting set up for episode
9 where by that point han Luke Leia the
original cast members that brought us a
lot of Hope or are now all dead which
forces half force which forces the
entire audience to put all their hope
into these new
cast members like rey finn po with
primarily ray being or savior because
she would be the last Jedi so making her
the official last Jedi would make for an
epic conclusion in episode 9 where all
of our hope is going into the last Jedi
also the newest Jenna if you make her
the official last Jedi for episode 9
would make the stakes a lot higher and
make it a little bit more of an underdog
story where it's like okay ray is the
last job but she's also the newest Jedi
and now all of our hope is going into
her saving the galaxy but then again I
know the word Jedi kid not just be a
singular word but also a plural word so
this could be referring to Luke and Ray
being the last Jedi but then some people
say that like you know you have to be a
little bit more specific it was
singularly Jedi Knight but who knows I
mean what do you guys think at the time
I think the title sounds pretty cool
certainly got me intrigued it's making
me though I want to find out what this
is a whole without making me more
intrigued it's making me ask more
questions and and I think the marketing
behind the force awakens was brilliant
and I feel like the marketing here is
going to be exceptionally more enticing
as well now that title just adds a lot
more stakes to the situation so I'm
excited for it what do you guys think of
it you're near the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
the greg alba and i love you mom you
never watch my videos and i completely
understand why